All right, we have so much to get you today
that I will take no more than 15 seconds just
to say thanks to David Samuels and Nicholas
Guzman.
Today's new David Pakman show, members of
the day.
And a big thank you to Michael Montay Ngara,
who is today's Long-Term Sustaining member.
He's been a member for five years.
Support the show at Join Pacman dot com with
a membership.
OK, we have leaked audio of an absolute mad
man rant by the president.
This happened during a call that Donald Trump
had yesterday with governors from around the
country.
The calls were about the protests.
The calls were in advance of Donald Trump
going out into the Rose Garden and saying,
if you don't scale up force, I will do it
for you by sending the military to your states.
These are, simply put, the rantings of an
agitated lunatic authoritarian who sounds
very desperate, who sounds very scared and
realizes he is quickly losing control that
he probably never even really had.
Let's take a listen to it.
The context is totally impotent.
Trump, who was tweeting insults and threats
all weekend from the White House while adults
actually tried to figure out what to do.
So, first of all, Donald Trump says here,
I guess, that he's saying that the Minneapolis
police were are a laughing stock.
Take a listen.
What happened in the state of Minnesota?
They were the laughingstock all over the world.
They took over the police department.
The police were running down the street.
Cyrus, Swazis are innocent.
He was on camera.
And that's a life job.
You probably have to build a new life.
But I've never seen anything like it.
The whole world was laughing.
Joiner's four days later, I still see the
color of the compass.
I think a quality that I.
And all of a sudden, the National Guard just
picked up just outside the gate.
So there is Trump bragging about when the
police became more militarized, they started
carving through crowds of protesters like
butter.
Just disgusting language.
And for Trump, this is all sport.
It's all visual.
It's what is Fox News showing when Trump turns
on the channel?
Let's continue.
It only gets worse from here, unfortunately.
Sort of dominated is just last night.
So here's Donald Trump again making the case
that forces police forces need to be militarized.
This is part of the problem in the United
States.
Understand that we have a situation here where
we have protests and unrest which were catalyzed
by police using too much force and killing
George Floyd.
And Trump is demanding that law enforcement
use even more force.
It's it could not possibly be more backwards
than here.
Is Trump again continuing in this leaked audio
of a call with governors using the language
of the domination of protesters.
Take a look.
Dominate.
That's going to mean that I have no idea.
Do you have spiders?
They're going to be allowed to fill their
jobs.
I don't know what's happening as it happened,
but it's terrible.
That's because New York, because it's for
that, it gets a lot of blood.
So.
They really spent a lot of time on it.
But do you want this guy to have to tough
it up and let's say your National Guard, if
you want, get the largest police force in
the country?
40000 people, I understand.
But what's going to go hysterical?
It's doubtful.
The whole place outside of Los Angeles with
a source of discomfort is careful.
Again, the police fought police forces must
toughen up.
We'll send soldiers, you have to dominate
the protesters.
Trump reportedly angry throughout the entire
call.
Trump said leaders should be seeking retribution.
This is the language of a mob boss.
This is not the language of a president of
the United States faced with unrest, the likes
of which we've not seen for a long time.
Trump told governors, you don't have to be
too careful.
In other words, don't be too careful.
Do the opposite of being careful.
Trump does not know how to lead.
He simply does not have to listen.
He doesn't have the cognitive capacity to
deal with the complexity of this situation.
We have to concede that.
And his view is this over aggressive view
of let's dominate the protesters.
He seems afraid, not literally of the protesters,
but of what this could do to his presidency.
But it is just not within him to lead.
He doesn't have any tools, as I said yesterday.
And a lot of people wrote to me and said,
David, that this felt like the right metaphor
or analogy and I didn't come up with it.
If you only have a hammer, everything looks
like a nail.
And that is exactly the situation we have.
Trump has very few tools and he he doesn't
have a velvet glove the way he himself once
analogized.
He has a couple of different sized hammers.
And so everything looks like a nail to him.
His tools are shaming people, insulting people,
making threats.
That's what he's doing here, even though it's
absolutely the last thing that we need.
So we have to realize at this point many things.
But I'll focus on two important realizations
that we need to come to.
And I know many of you have probably come
to these realizations already.
Number one, we aren't going to get anything
but more of this from Donald Trump.
Period.
No matter the circumstances, no matter what
is necessary, no matter what is called for.
These are his routines.
And this is all he can really do.
Staged photo ops at the church that we talked
about earlier, the military deployments.
Same governors.
You better get it together.
You guys are jerks or incompetent or whatever
else.
That's no.
That's all we are going to get from Trump.
Number two, there is a possibility that Trump
actually sees more chaos is good for him,
especially if he can frame as a frame it as
this is the merely the left doing bad things,
which they've started to do yesterday.
Yesterday, I covered live Trump's press secretary,
Caly McEnany, did a press briefing and she
must have talked about an TIFA, you know,
what, a dozen times, two dozen times.
And this is a calculated strategy.
They talk about an TIFA to dismiss and disqualify
the overwhelmingly peaceful protesters.
The actual issues that launched these protests.
Now, I don't know if it will work.
This may be a miscalculation by Donald Trump
or it may work if the virus continues, if
the chaos continues, if the country continues
to see no leadership from Donald Trump.
And meanwhile, Joe Biden keeps meeting with
protesters and staking out a position on police
treatment of minorities.
That addresses the systemic problems.
This doesn't mean Joe Biden is a hero.
This means nothing other than on this issue
right now.
Right.
You can talk about Biden in 94 right now.
Joe Biden is showing more leadership and understanding
of this issue than is Donald Trump.
I don't know that Trump is going to come away
from this unscathed or with with an increased
approval rating because it doesn't look like
he's doing anything right now.
There's a new national poll out from NBC,
from ABC, from over the weekend, which has
Joe Biden at plus 10 points nationally against
Donald Trump.
This is an unconscionable number.
This is on the high end.
Polls are generally showing Biden leading
by between four and 11 nationally.
So certainly 10 is on the high end.
But what is it that will come from what Trump
is doing that will close the gap with Biden,
whether you believe the gap is four or 10
or seven?
What is it that Trump is doing that will close
the gap?
It's hard to imagine his supporters will be
with him no matter what.
But consider the backwards nature of Trump's
reaction.
And this is what I keep going back to.
The protests were started by the brutal handling
of a black man by Minnesota police.
So what does Trump do?
He says you governors need to be more aggressive.
And I will send federal military to be more
aggressive if you don't do it.
I don't know that this will work.
I hope that it doesn't work because it's absolutely
horrifying.